[Music]
i
have always felt if you know what you're
going to do in advance
then you won't do it your creativity
starts with whether you're curious or
not
roll em go action
when you build a building any building
start with the simple block model
to see where that goes most of our
cities are built with
just faceless glass only for economies
and not for humanities as an artist
i got constraints gravity is one of them
but within all those constraints
i have 15 of freedom
to make my art
i'm always trying to express movement
i was fascinated with the fold so basic
to our
first feelings of love and warmth
these ideas are scary as hell
to tell to the client they can reject
you
and they will but you got to find your
own
voice create the logic for it as you go
stretch it into another place
i'm just telling you how i did it and
why i did it whatever you do
promise me that every project you make
for design
you'll take the risk of doing something
for humanity
i'm frank gehry and this is my master
class
i think i know when to quit
you